could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
music is game of thrones bro when you
see game of thrones they kill the main
character do you what i'm saying they
don't mind doing that wembley makes the
noise for reds feature together
i think the best turning point for me
was when i was 16 and my mom threw me
out she feels like it was a harsh thing
to do but i'm like at the end of the day
if you don't do that for me at 16 i
don't become rich
we signed for a single which was tractor
that was my ringtone twin said to me he
was like this song was going to change
your life and then yeah bam it goes in
the charts and everything changed after
that
the obsession
made me better made me more hungry when
you find your passion here you find your
calling bro you're not fair to no one
everyone comes second bro my daughter
she has no recognition of living with me
i just became a monster man i just you
can't skip what's important man how many
we get 80 years maybe now your legacy
can can triple that broke have the right
one what if it just hadn't worked out
it had to
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
rich
take me back to tottenham when you're
growing up um i'm a big believer and to
be honest i always start these podcasts
in the same way because i came to learn
when i was younger the importance of
those early years on shaping who we
become as adults and someone said this
wonderful quote to me that we're
actually just children living out the
stories we told ourselves about
ourselves long ago
so take me back to tottenham where you
grew up in the context in which made you
the man you are today grew up in seven
sisters in a state called tibetan
tottenham was just notorious in it for a
lot of madness a lot of crime a lot of
this a lot of that
and i think
for me just growing up and learning how
to navigate through that how to
understand who you are what you're here
for
and also my parents and grandparents and
all that they were proper embedded
in you know fighting against police
brutality so i always had
a lot of understanding about certain
things that were probably above my age i
feel like i was always someone that
could get along with everyone like
whether our cool kid uncle kid whatever
i like i could always
have something to speak about with
anyone and i think throughout life
that's always helped me and it's always
been beneficial but i definitely started
when i was young
um
in their state just like the regular the
regular stuff man that was happening you
know i'm saying like a lot of
badness um
stabbings a lot of this a lot of that
but we just when we were very young we
just wanted to play football you know i
mean when it's a play out play football
play games but as you get older you
you know you start seeing other things
hearing other things and
sometimes even
not even i wouldn't say not unwillingly
sometimes you're just you become a part
of things because you're there on the
day or you're there at that time
and i think a lot of
them early scenarios kind of shaped
who i thought i was going to become at
that time
the best turning point
for me
was when i was 16 and my mum threw me
out
because
i now had to be the adult that i thought
i was
so before that i was you know walking
around the house had a bravado had
attitude for i was a big man for i was a
bad boy for i was whatever
and you know all the time my mom's kind
of like single mom you know there's um
at that time there's a three two older
sisters and two younger sisters and
myself
in the house and just like
at that time just feeling like i'm
feeling myself a bit too much and my mom
was always like look i know you feel
you're beyond your years but you're not
you're actually 15 or you actually fall
in and if you continue moving like this
you're going to be forced to be 21 at
16.
obviously as a you you're not really
taking that in taking it serious one day
i come home and my bags are on the door
so i'm kind of like all right cool and
i'm like
mad prideful as well so
at the time my sisters were like look
just have a conversation with her
she's gonna throw it out just calm down
a bit whatever whatever but i'm just
feeling myself still too much so i'm
kind of just like whatever i took my
bags went to my cousin's house for a
little while
then i just felt like i was just in
other people's space obviously their
family but i just felt like i'm in the
way i don't like feeling like that went
to my sisters
still did feel like i was in the way
even though to her she'll say i wasn't
but
like i just don't want to be a burden to
anyone so then yeah just went to the
housing and yeah 16 years old i was in
my place and i learned so much man and i
think that's the best the best thing
anyone's ever done for me in my life why
did she throw you out
i was too
too vibing man i just thought i was too
i thought i was it
do you get what i'm saying and i think
as well it's like
when you think you're it and you're
making a little money on the roads and
whatever and you're giving someone money
here and there
you're thinking you're doing your part
so maybe i'll give you 200 this month
maybe next month i don't give you
anything maybe the next month i'll give
you a grand maybe the next two months i
don't give you anything but
i'm always reverting back to the fact
that yeah but i gave you yeah but i gave
you oh yeah but i've done this so yeah
but i've done that but what you don't
realize until your adult is every month
the bills are coming
they don't come staggered like you're
giving the money so it's not like
she can't just pay 600 pound rent in
january and nothing in february do you
know what i'm saying so it's like
but you don't have that understanding as
a child you need to be an adult to have
that understanding like these bills are
coming regardless
and i think
even though she was saying it to me i
was still you know like you're still
calculating what you're giving like no
but i gave oh but i've done this so i've
done that
it's not enough the bills don't work
like that being 16 and learning them
harsh lessons this is harsh reality and
i was just like right i actually thought
i was a big man and it's like
like years i i was angry with my mum for
a bit at the time as you would be not
speaking to her kind of like kind of
trying to be like that but you know like
letters are still going there so he's
still getting there i'll get asked my
sister give me the letter bring out the
letters don't really want to go in
whatever still you know being attached
to pride and being attached to too much
attitude and i just had to like humble
myself one day and i'd just be like you
know what mom that was the best thing
anyone's ever done for me and she was
like to this day like when she hears me
say it she still it still upsets her
because she feels like it was you know
very a harsh thing to do but i'm like at
the end of the day if you don't do that
for me at 16 i don't become rich at
20 odd because he's too comfortable
rich comes out of being uncomfortable
being backed in the corner being forced
to be
you know to be a provider being forced
to be the man of his house rather than
thinking he's the man of his mom's house
the man of your house did you know your
father
yeah yeah did you have a relationship
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah my dad's a very
was very very serious man very serious
very serious very strict
very well respected because of
you know in the area with all the the
police brutality and all of that all the
things that they fought for and still
fight for him my uncle and my nan but
just very very very harsh very harsh and
and the dj as well so old school you
remember they used to string up sound
systems
like my mom's house like all the
speakers throughout the passage
one of the rooms all the speakers like
all of us had to share because the
speakers had their own room you know i'm
saying i'm like mom
can't i at least sleep in the in the
speaker like i'm sharing with my sisters
i need a little space or whatever but um
yeah so yeah yeah good relationship
obviously him and my mom parted ways
and um
yeah still still kept a relationship
like i don't have that
i don't know my dad thing like i know my
dad yeah
and uh your grandmother one of the
things you said about her was that
watching her
take care of your grandfather
who had cancer
yeah um was what a really pivotal moment
watching how sort of caring she was with
him and right up until the point that he
passed away
you know like when you're young
your first experiences of death are like
so severe man like so impactful not that
not that it gets any easier but you
understand it more i think when you get
older
and i just think at the time
i don't i don't i've never
understood strength until i met
that situation with my grandma and it
was just
how she how she was you know like
caribbean so when i'd come around she's
like make sure you come back again you
know because i'm soon dead and i'm
saying you're saying to me he soon did
like he's not gonna die i don't even
understand the severity of cancer as
young as i was at that time
she's like yeah man i'm soon dead
managed that and all my friends that he
liked she's like make sure you bring
them to say goodbye and i'm like say
goodbye like what the hell this
everything's cool but it's like
she's saying it to me like that but my
mom and my dad they're not like
explaining the severity of the situation
to me they're not saying like
there's a countdown so i've got my aunt
saying like yo we're giving him organic
food we're doing this so i'm thinking yo
we're fighting it but every time i'm
going back
it's like
he's becoming like i don't know less and
less and smaller and smaller and now i
can
see it but i'm still i don't know i
guess the words naive in it that you're
very hopeful and you're naive thinking
nah nah nah it's going to be cool
because he'd been to be fair he'd been
saying he was sick for years but he was
undiagnosed he was ill but we didn't
know when he went to the doctor he died
once he got diagnosed it's a countdown
now so i don't know if mentally
something
happens there i don't know if how that
works but
just watching a
you know through when he became in was
incontinent like washing him
buffing him feeding him just being there
the whole way through i was just like
that to me is was the real definition of
a marriage that is
you know um sickness and health do you
know what i'm saying that is death do us
part that was literally till death do us
part and i'm like
i don't know if i'd ever see that level
of strength again the other thing that i
really stuck out to me about your
childhood as i was reading through your
backstory was that moment when you're
nine and a car comes up next to you yeah
tell me about that what happened uh what
did that teach you at that point like
tottenham was warring with a lot of
surrounding areas in it so
it was like food fiestas back then
tinted cars rolling through the estate
just
looking for whoever they're looking for
but i live in the middle of it and being
young but being tall
and remember back then when when when
everyone's warm with each other like now
we have the internet so everyone knows
who everyone is what everyone looks like
whatever back then nobody didn't it was
just a description like he's dark
skinned and skinny
do you get what i'm saying so they're
coming looking for a dark skin and
skinny guy but i'm nine
and i'm going shop and then i remember
the car was breezing up to me
and i'm thinking right why is it driving
like that skids
wind down the window and then i look in
the car i'm like bro
but it's like it's just like
nah nah and then drive off and i just
thought wow like what the hell like just
imagine if i ran like because you know
that for a second i was gonna run and i
was thinking right the cars because he's
driving towards me i can run that way
ain't gonna be able to spin around but i
just remember thinking like
i haven't even done anything do you know
what i'm saying first of all but then
when it stopped and they've done that i
was like
let's drive off and i think that thing
there made me feel like
it's probably better to be involved than
to not
at the time
do you get what i'm saying because at
the time i'm not involved i'm actually
just a clean-hearted good you i just
play football and computer that's it you
guys i'm saying so when that happened it
made me feel like right that could have
happened to me for no reason
like i might as well give you a reason
do you know what i'm saying someone
could have done something yeah something
something could have like i could have
been shot whatever they was gonna do and
i think that kind of put a chip on my
shoulder do you know what i mean for the
next
the next couple years which obviously is
what led to my mum feeling like now
you're feeling yourself a bit too much
go and fly the nest like if you don't
you know if you don't
if you don't push the bird out then this
it won't fly you know if you're not
throwing in the water you don't have to
swim kind of thing and a lot of men i
mean this happens
not just on the estate but men that
don't grow up in such circumstances they
start using that like bravado as a as a
form of self-defense but it ends up
um inflicting self-harm in some way i
mean that's what you tend to see with a
lot of gangs right you join for to
defend yourself or to try and fit in but
it leads you down a path of self-harm
yeah because you go from
i'm doing this to fight back yeah and
then you go from fighting back in the
form of defense to offense now because
it's gone from i'm just defending myself
to now i'm out in a club or i'm out
somewhere
and
now you're getting into situations with
people that you feel
look like
you might end up in a situation with so
now it's just happening now it's
proactive yeah i'm saying
if you both
were just defending yourselves then you
can be cool to walk past each other or
be in the same club at the same time or
whatever
i think a lot of like things being
unsaid
like when things ain't clear like you're
in just because you're in an environment
and you feel
i don't know you might not have an issue
with anyone in the environment but
because there's no clarity yeah because
they haven't said we don't have enough
of you and you haven't said we don't
have nothing with you it's just tense
yeah yeah i mean that's life right
relationships you know what i mean is
communication yeah there's just a little
tenseness and it's like why is it tense
and then
depending on how the ice breaks i'm
saying if it breaks the right way it's
cool if it breaks the wrong way
then it's just erupting into something
that didn't even exist to be fair in the
first place and at that age what did you
want to be when you grew up what was the
aspiration
probably wanted to be ian wright
realized early on that ain't gonna
happen
um i liked music
i didn't want to be a musician though
why
it didn't seem realistic
you didn't know anyone in your tribal
circle that i had gone yeah it was like
the musicians were like other people
jay-z yeah you know i'm saying tupac or
naz like that was
somewhere else so it's like yeah you can
do it for fun so we do it for fun we
write whatever i record
on tapes blah blah blah but i never
thought like
this could be a career i could make
money from this i could live in this
space
so i guess like i was into trying to
understand what else happens outside my
estate because because also what happens
you feel like
your family your friends become your
family in the estate
the sweet shop is basically a
supermarket
um
so you don't need to leave you just move
from house to house then we're all
outside we play football then it's 9 p.m
we buy ice poles then everyone goes home
we do it again tomorrow and you just end
up
in a cycle of that but then someone told
me
actually i saw one of my friends in an
advert
a guy from my estate called frank yeah
he was in a lexus advert
as a kid and i was like when he when he
come when i tell you i was like mom
that's francis he was over there i said
frank when i saw him i said frank how
did you get an advert he was like i've
got an agent how's that is it how do you
get agent
who's that there's a newspaper that
comes out every thursday called the
stage so it's like by the stage it costs
a pound but it just shows you so much
different things so i used to buy that
newspaper yeah just to see like
what else can happen like what else is
there and it should be like
auditions or whatever to be fair i never
really go to any but i think like
i was just intrigued about like what
else exists like what other people are
doing then i'd see something about the
british school i'm like i wonder what
that is like all these things that we
don't know nothing about anna shears i
used to see sylvia young
all these things in the paper but there
was always a price a cost like sign up
for this or pay for the portfolio or
whatever and obviously at like 11 12
13 years you can't you know i mean my
mom she's not gonna
there's too many of us to ask for that
we need school uniform first and
foremost everything else is secondary so
um yeah
how old are you and you decided that you
were gonna like record a mixtape
and like publish it and try and sell it
2006 when it came out yeah 2006
learn from my mixtape
came out that's my first
cd 24 songs on there
i tried getting it on spotify i couldn't
no it's not it's not i need to you know
i need to get it up one day people ask
but i think there might be one or two
american beats right so that's why we're
struggling with that but um
yeah man i think at that point i'd been
on pirate radio i've been on heat fm
and i was just like
then i became obsessed i was obsessed i
was just like i need to go studio
as much as i can everything i was doing
was to put into being able to record and
then once i had
seven or eight cds with about
nine songs on each it's like right what
about 50
60 some songs like this is mad maybe i
should just do
do a project so then i came up with the
idea learned from my mixtape because i
wanted it to be like quite educational
like not in a school way but in a
streets way like i always wanted to like
educate the youth and let them know
there was other ways of doing things
kind of thing that's always been my
thing
so yeah came up with that made that
project
the funny thing about that cd is that
you give it to the guy to press up you
pay your six or seven hundred pound and
then he
he presses it up but there back then
they were so long you're rigging him
every friday is it has it arrived no
it's not arrived yet
ringing ringing ringing ringing
so the day my son's born
i'm in the hospital i get a phone call
and it's the guy and i'm like
so the baby's born healthy everything's
cool answer the phone he's like you see
these are here
come now because he's not i don't know i
don't remember if it was a friday but he
wasn't in tomorrow he wasn't in for the
next two days
so he was like come now so obviously
i'll come off the phone
i'm in the hospital holding my son
so like his mom's looked at me and she's
like who was that i was like yeah man
the cds are here but she knows that this
is my thing so this is like
but this is the thing when you make
music you're obsessed bro
you're obsessed so i'm like looking at
my watch like
yeah i'm saying she's like
then she just looks at me and she goes
to go and get the cds man just go and
get the cds i'm like
thank you man
jumped in the car ripped the cred and
picked up a thousand cds
thousands you got them all in the car
thousand all in the car bro thousand
like seats two of us in the car seats
down
cut like a thousand it takes up bare
space as well
got them back
so then like just
put them in the hallway
when i picked them up brought her home
and she was just like you need to get
these out of this house because now
there's a buggy
there's moses basket there's all of this
stuff i'm just like i'm just feeling mad
pressure i'm just like
that was just it was just fun and
exciting man it was like it was like my
life was born
was reborn my son was born i just felt
like a new
energy i was re-energized and i just i
just wanted to go man so it was like
spent the next couple weeks doing the
salem return
so you take them to a shop if they don't
sell them they come back bro and at that
point i don't care about the money bro i
just want to be heard like i want
someone drove past me and they were
playing my cd bro you can't tell me i'm
not jay-z back then when i heard that
and i don't know the person normally you
know them i'm looking i'm like right he
doesn't even notice me he's driving past
me i'm like yeah this is like this is
happening we're growing we're growing so
yeah just re-energize man and sale in
return is long because you're no one
the the shop guy he shows up fool so
he's like yeah we'll take five
i'm like my guy i have a thousand of
these take 50 bro i won't even come back
for the money i swear to you bro like
i'm cool bro he's like nah nah give me
ten
bro you know what i'm doing just to get
rid of them i'll buy the 10 back yeah
and then he'll call me and he'll be like
yeah the 10 went fast you know that'll
make someone else do it doesn't matter
if i don't lie what do you want you want
a 50 now yeah yeah bring the 50 yeah
we've got 50 for you coming so you'd get
a friend to go in and buy this yes you
get what i'm saying so now i can go and
give him 50 that's half a box out bro
this was taking up so much space so yeah
doing that
oxford circus birmingham cried and like
all the music shops and yeah it was
different time in it when you were
running around shot on those cds what
were you doing for money because i'm
sure that wasn't that wasn't covering
the bills right
now me and my my manager he's my manager
now he was just he's always been my
virgin like my right hand we just
every every penny we made from anything
we just put it together and put it in
this and put it in this so it's like
sometimes we'd go back for the sale and
return as well so we'd get a little
drips and drabs there this and that and
just
literally just sharing money it's like
we had one bank account if i'm honest
like it was we're just sharing like
anything
what do we need then we needed to do a
video how much does a video cost 2 500.
whoa
all right cool but now
my um
at the time like my son's mum's like yo
we need
buggy let's say we need a buggy but it's
like i need to do a video it was like i
felt like i was always trying to decide
between a bug or a video yeah bro that
you feel so guilty but you but you know
it made me understand it made me
understand
like the the need and the obsession and
the love i have for this thing because
i'm actually always comparing it like it
sounds mad to hear
me say but it's just when it's your
purpose is your purpose bro every single
month we're growing we're growing we're
growing it's getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger and when it gets
to that point we'll have
how many buggies do you get i'm saying
we have the best car everything it will
be able to spin what you get i'm saying
they'll put the cop will put the baby to
sleep whatever you know what i mean sma
champagne um
so yeah but that was like that was when
i was understanding that you've like
you've actually got some kind of
obsession or
some deep rooted love for this thing
that should probably not be like that
you know what i'm saying like what
you're weighing up against the other
thing it just
but it just was man how long were you in
that phase of like trying to like trying
to give people your cds and like how how
in years or months how long was that
that phase where like people weren't
because i was watching the kanye netflix
yeah documentary recently
it reminded me of that that you got that
young man who believed in himself more
than anyone else did you see that scene
where he plays like bro it
all falls down all falls down and she's
not paying attention she goes on the
phone yeah yeah she's on the phone she's
intentionally trying to tell him to piss
off ignoring
it reminds me of that like
so how long were you in that phase of
your journey just like selling them cds
i think so if this first cd came out
2006 i reckon since like 2003 i'd been
giving out music but what i was always
very clever at like i always wanted
everyone
to like my music so i had different cds
with different songs on so i'd have like
a cd with 10 gram songs
a cd with 10 love songs a cd with five
songs about trying to turn your life
around i just had different cds and what
i'd do
i'd give the cd
to each person as to what i think they
would like
so i give the man name that one but what
was happening is that i gave a man that
and then i gave his sister a different
one but his sister was like yeah but my
brother's got one that's got different
songs on but i'm not i don't think you'd
like that so it was like i was always
just i had music enough music to please
everyone but then everyone wanted the
other songs as well so that kind of made
me decide that you know what if you put
everything on 24 songs then maybe they
can all be centered to this disc and it
can start there and it worked yeah
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you 20 grams of protein
if you haven't tried the cured protein
product do give it a try the salted
caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
2003 2006 you were trying to move them
cds mixtape comes out 2006. yeah but
what
what were you using as metrics to figure
out if it was actually working
bro if if i heard my song on the radio
we was winning
every time i heard it i was like cool
i'm a manager
we are ying and young like i'm all
creative and this guy is ooh
genius in another way so he would be
like i'd go to his house and he'd be
like all right cool we're going to this
show in nottingham
these people are performing when you see
this guy he thinks he knows you yeah
because i've messaged him off your
account and you'd have had a
conversation so just make sure you say
hello to him
i'm just like have you even how do you
even know who's who but he'd already
engineered some idea and
so then we we we were like proper that
the first station to proper
like really show us mad love was like
one extra so it's like dj cameo
ace and veers like all these bras kwame
all these twin b like all these people
were just showing mad love like come in
man do an interview and like i like to
think i'm likable people like to
conversate so with talking and then
this guy would introduce me to a
producer then the producer would
introduce me to
a next person then we found out about
press and pr and started working with a
guy called charlie at visions and he was
like yeah you pay us 500 a month and we
can get you in magazines like right
magazines crazy like it was just like
everything was just
one person away so each person
introduced us to a different person and
that's how i'm
how i was measuring the growth so i'm
like i can come back and i'm like yo man
i just met this guy manny he shoots
videos or i met this guy he does pr i
met this guy he's a photographer like
and she's in her head she's probably
thinking oh shut up yeah like what's the
photographer gonna do but i'm like it's
another step
each step each step each step one hand
is washing the other and we will wash
the whole body i promise you know what i
mean like
in that in that phase you're starting to
get these radio plays and stuff which is
kind of like a sign for you it's that
reinforcement that things you're moving
in the right direction yeah was there
and i'm sure you get asked this a lot
but was there a moment when
even
your partner at the time said to you do
you know what
i think oh you could see it because
sometimes they don't say you can see it
in their face yeah when they hear it on
the radio they see you know yeah i
always knew that i was ticking her off
man
like in that interesting in that not in
everyone in that in that aspect because
even like at them times i used to write
at home
bro i don't know if you've lived with a
musician i've been around a musician bro
that beat is on loop for hours
you get what i'm saying and all i would
hear like when i pull it back is just
like as if you do again and i just was
like you know what i need to just start
working in the studio because this
like it's not fair like it's
when you find your passion here you find
your calling bro you're not fair to no
one you only fear to yourself you know
i'm saying you're not fair to anyone
everyone
everyone comes second bro everyone and
it's not intentional it just it just is
what it is so
me thinking that i'm spending time with
her because i'm writing in the house
even though i'm not talking to her the
song's just on loop and i'm writing i'm
thinking i'm spending time i ain't
spending time
do you i'm saying that's just being
present
so it's like
but then it's like in my head i'm
thinking yeah but if i'm in a studio for
eight hours i'm
at home yeah i'm at home but it's it's
actually all about me bro it was only
all about me my calling
and making this making this music like i
wake up every day i think music before i
go to sleep i think music i used to have
a dream that happened every time
and
in the dream i'm in a studio and i'm
writing a verse
and i'd wake up and i'm like i can never
remember the verse and i'm trying to
remember trying to remember
one day i woke up i'm like i need i had
a pen and paper by my bed i left it
there i wrote out the verse that i wrote
in my dream i was like bro this is like
to me i'm like i'm believing in this now
i'm like this is this has to be
fake or something like this has to be
engineered by someone higher than you
man like from your writing in your sleep
literally
so just
and just going and going and going
i want to get up to the point when you
release black and white in 2011. yeah
what happens between that mixtape coming
out in 2006 to 2011 is that what are the
most significant moments or pivotal
moments where things took a a turn in a
good direction okay like more
more exposure and little things
happening here and there like mtv asked
us to do
something for black history month it was
like a freestyle
that was strong because it showed
people i could write perform stick to
topic
then one extra gave us
an award for getting
i think one of our records was the most
played right so it was like that was
quite cool like most street heat that
was dj centex is that punctuation i
think it's punctuation yeah punctuation
getting a lot more bookings
and
twin b
twin b from one extra um
always having conversations with him
like he just
gave me an understanding
of the game on on the other side because
at the time he was working with at
ministry
and he just had so many gems and he made
me understand because i used to think
like why am i not signed like why was i
not signed why am i not saying i'm not
good or that's not about good or great
it's about
timing and it's about what can a label
help you do how can a label help you be
bigger what do you need to achieve
before you step into a label
so with all these conversations
you know doing loads of collaborations
as well
and then richard antoi and twin b
they form a record label called levels
and they're like we want to sign you man
and i'm like
bro okay like what happens now kind of
thing it's like now you need a lawyer
now you need you know all these other
things and it was just like
once it got to that point
i knew that i was serious because
richard anthony had worked with adele
so many different people do you i'm
saying and i knew that this guy was
serious twin music lover we'd had
endless conversations on the phone about
music
and they had their situation with
ministry of sound so they were like a
subsidiary of ministry of sounds it was
like center levels like
you know and ministry as well
and i just
i just knew that that was the right
thing to do at the time
when you get that news that yeah they
want to sign you
what's ashley saying
do you come home and you're like ah yeah
we've
um
i don't think i do you know
i think i guess by that point
just me being about me the
relationship's not where it it could
have been a way it should have been you
know i mean so i think by that time
we're already
going our separate ways yeah kind of
drifting apart
but um
yes i didn't get to
to kind of have that that thing but i
think
i think she's you know she's happy for
me always been happy for me always one
always knew that this was what i needed
to do
she knew that it was a need and not a
one
because of the things what everything i
was weighing it up against she knew that
this is a need like
this guy needs to do this like he needs
it so yeah
and then black and white and then black
and white yeah so initially we signed
for a single
which was tractor
that was my ringtone that was 2012. yeah
that was my ringtone i don't even know
what phone it was but it was my ringtone
when i first i did one day at university
before i dropped out and that was my my
ringtone from day one my guy yeah we had
that record and twin said to me
when i put the verses down
he was like this song was to change your
life really he said that yeah and i was
like i don't know how you know that but
you're my guy so i'm believing in you
and i'm like
i just didn't know
what would happen next
so i'm still going back to them times
when i'd go to the record shops yeah and
kind of
buy back the cds to give more so when
i'm out in the club if they're playing
the tune
or they're not playing the tune i'm
making sure they play the song you know
i'm saying like i'm saying yeah what
does it take what all the drinks cool a
lot of drinks play that song when the
dreams come
like i'm making sure that this song is
being heard we're trying everything
we're not trying to we're our fingers
always floor to ceiling we'd say we'd
make sure we'd covered everything floor
to ceiling and then yeah bam it goes in
the charts and
literally everything changed
everything changed after that take me
through that process so it goes in the
charts and then you start just what's it
like because i've you know never had a i
never had a hit
bro it's like
you get throughout that week
sort of say like the songs available to
buy on sunday it was back then
so monday morning
like the labels kind of knows the
numbers in it so they're kind of like
your number
eight
i'm like bro number eight they're like
yeah but we'll catch
we'll catch seven and six
maybe five
then the next day it's like yeah you're
number six i'm like what the hell like
and it's just going higher then it gets
to four i think and it goes back to five
and it's like it's five and it's like
right we've got one hold in in in the
top five
and it's just
i don't know i just think at that time
yeah you just
you almost
step into a vehicle and then it just
starts moving
and it's like you know like when you're
driving
through an area you're looking at the
window you're just seeing things and
you're just seeing people and
but you're just moving it just it was
just moving bro like it was just moving
it was moving and then
you're doing glastonbury and then you're
doing
wireless and you're doing v festival
when you're doing everything was just
moving everything was everything
happened so fast that
i don't think i don't think i even
stopped to take it in at that time
and then it and then it was
cool you done it once that was one
single now we want to do an album what's
the next single that's like now you've
got to do it again and it's like i
didn't even really know
how i'd done it in the first place if
i'm honest like you i'm saying it was a
cool song sounded good and it worked and
then it was just like okay make second
single and then made a second single
while making the album and it was just
it was just moving man everything was
just it was it was it happens you know
when they say like
you you wait your whole life or does it
happen overnight literally waited a
whole life was it happened overnight and
it and once it happened it just didn't
stop it just kept the ball kept rolling
man were you prepared for it
mentally
and i don't know socially we prepared
for that train to pick you up and and
drag you off into
your dream like that
i don't think so now but i think luckily
the only thing i wanted to do still at
that time was make music
i think if i wanted
to i can see like how like you know like
a artist has a hit
and then just all over the papers and
just getting involved in different
things i can see how that can happen
temptation right yeah because you end up
in other places
other than where you should be but for
me it was still always about the studio
like i'd go raving but
i'd go raving at one o'clock because the
engineer's tired or the producer's tired
and we finished and
i i don't have the best night's sleep i
don't sleep too well so
it's one o'clock yeah i'd go out but
then tomorrow it was studio like it was
always i was always in and locked in so
i didn't veer from that so i think
in a sense i wasn't prepared for one
side of it but for what i needed to do i
was prepared for and i was serious about
my half my half of the deal yeah
and then so that album becomes a huge
success um a real breakthrough moment
for you
um
and then obviously when the album's done
you have another pressure right which is
the expectation of that album right
bro
go again do you what i'm saying like
flip a coin
10 times
and get heads yeah all right cool now do
another 10. do you know what i'm saying
it's literally like how am i gonna
yeah get heads every time every time i'm
saying get heads go and do it well
you've done it do it go
for me like
making music is the part that i'm in
control of
i never feel pressured about that never
because i have i have what i have to say
i feel what i feel
and i'm gonna pour all of that into
music i'm going to put all of that into
that album no problem
i just think at that time what
what was getting tricky was
ministry was kind of happy
that we'd had three top five singles and
was kind of just
you know more as a business more happy
to stay in that domain like yeah let's
just turn out the hits
and i think
after
black and white and all of that and all
the things like
you know just
i think i had a lot of frustration in me
and
and and it was it was almost
it's almost the side of my life which i
i saw my uncle and my dad and all of
that talking about the police like that
side of me was coming out whereas i'd
always mention it in my music i just
felt
like i
i wanted i i had something else to say
you know i'm saying everything happened
with mark duggar and all of that and i
was like i need to speak about
what's going on and and i think
it was it was a bit of a difference of
opinion you know i'm saying ministry of
sound wanted these kind of songs ain't
hit record so it was a bit of
a bit of friction so we had to work our
way
you know around that and it was just
about
you know getting to the point where we
could release that album which was
growing over life and it was just
for me it was
it was it was important that i released
that record man
and and following black and white when
you look back on how you reacted and you
know that tension with the label and
stuff like that
in your maturity and wisdom now
is there do you wish you'd behaved
differently following the the release of
that album and its success is there
something you wish you would
you know
in with the wonder of high school yeah
yeah change nah
nah because i wasn't like
i wasn't aggressive i just like to
understand i like clarity
and i think what what can happen in an
industry is
not everybody wants to be crystal clear
whereas it's like if if you're crystal
clear with it and say you know what if
we can get another don't go
and another tractor and another blackout
then
whatever so it's like all right cool
then you understand an assignment of
what you're after but it's like if
you're not being crystal clear then it
kind of leaves you in limbo so you're
sending in songs
and it's just like
and they're not being clear about what
yes the feedback's a bit like
don't think this one's a single fact say
it was a single sister it was a song
that kind of thing you know what i mean
so it's like
yeah just trying to gain understanding i
think that was what my frustration was
was like just getting understand but
twin b obviously twin being richard and
always kept it 100 always was just like
look
if we can have if there's any moments
where we can i think they're like you
need to say what you need to say in it
you know what i'm saying and
if their other moments arise we'll find
them and you'll engineer them you're the
best at doing that you know when you're
comfortable to do it you do it i'm
saying ain't no pressure come in from
our way and i came up with six words
which was um
written within that
within that space and within that time
and i was like all right cool i've got
one the one you want
is the one you want kind of thing um
so yeah but i think with hindsight i
didn't like i didn't fly off the handle
i didn't
i didn't i didn't get angry i'm not i
didn't get aggressive it was pointless
did you stray away from your like your
principal passion of making music during
that phase did you did you find yourself
like not showing up obsessed in the
studio in the same way after that hit
because sometimes when people reach the
mountaintop they they lose a bit of
orientation and motivation sometimes and
you know there's other temptations now
you've got better money so you don't
need to be
the hunger's slightly different
no no
no love it like i think
for me
always wanting to be the best rapper
always wanting to say the sickest things
the things that people are like how did
you get to that i'm saying like
so that that never left me so like there
was always
freestyles there was always
you know always raps always versus you
know collaborations like at the time
like my manager zeon used to say to me
like he's just like bro sometimes you've
got to make something make sense like
these people are asking you for a
feature they want to pay you 20 bags of
us or 10 bucks a verse and you're saying
no
and your bridging around the corner is
rapping you're giving reverse for free
like we've got a i'm not saying don't do
the verse for free but i'm saying
i'm saying there's some over here that
make that verse make sense as well so
it's like also as well navigation and
just being like oh yeah yeah
you're right kind of thing and just some
things work well for positioning you
know i mean
as well but just always yeah just always
wanting to be the best
artist man just always wanting to have
the best album i think that's
something that's never left me and i
think if that does leave you
as an artist
that's probably when it's like you know
like when you see mike tyson in the ring
at the end
and he's fighting some guy you haven't
heard of
and he's just mashing him up and you're
just like mike man
do you i'm saying like mike five years
ago you would have finished him but he's
like
mike's not mike
do you know what i'm saying mike got
that
that same one you don't love it anymore
do you know what i'm saying the love's
gone you can see it in his eyes and i
feel like
if that happens to you as a musician
it's yeah it's not it's not good to kind
of like mess up your legacy man like one
of the things that's always made you
stand out even when i listen to your
fire in the booth and i listen to all of
them i have them on replay i actually
played one last night to my girlfriend i
was like right she's coming
i played uh the one you did with is it
yeah i played that one a lot
is the subject matter of what you write
about is isn't about
buying rolexes and fast cars
now
as a young black man myself um
i
tend to feel a sense of disappointment
when i go on instagram and i see like
the new school of like hip-hop artists
all putting their hands in and showing
their roles because for me
it's like leading
um
our people astray in the sense because i
would like them to show their investment
portfolio or their
the the equity they have in businesses
and stuff because
like
you know um what's your stance on that i
actually was gonna put some stuff on my
story the other day because i saw
i don't wanna name names because it's
not about individuals it's about a
culture um i saw some rappers that
actually follow me some big big hip-hop
uk rappers that follow me
all like showing off the material things
that really disappoints me because i
know there's thousands in this case
there's
800 000 people that follow this guy
and
they're now gonna aspire to buy gucci
before they invest their money or put it
away what's your thoughts on this i
think we've
growing up here i think like we were so
like bedazzled by
the american
rap culture
and we'd always seen them have things
have jewelry have all these things and
whatever and i think even myself at a
point
for me that was like a trophy or a
measure of success
do you know what i'm saying it's like
the rolex was a measure of success and i
and i think like like i've heard you say
yourself as well it's like once you get
it
it's like
it doesn't really make you feel
inside yeah it doesn't really give you
nothing like that and i think we haven't
had
we haven't had the luxury of
of information
and i think
information comes from people who look
like you and people who have been
through it had success and are able to
tell you so now i'm in that position i'm
able to talk to her 18 year old
and be like yeah man you can get that
but at the same time make sure you've
got that
one of the dumbest things i'd ever done
in my life i don't think i've said this
anyway is
so obviously when i
um my mom's got a council flat
bro when i signed my deal i left my
house i left the whole house and just
went left the council i left just left
it
but people at the time were saying to me
yo man
buy it like why don't you buy it and i'm
like i don't i'm not going to live here
like it was in tottenham i'm like i'm
not going to leave here i'm going to
yeah i'm saying no like no you don't
just buy it but the people that were
telling me to buy it didn't own a house
so i'm like what do you know yeah what
do you know that i live in
princess park manor do you know what i'm
saying now like this is gated community
like this is way better than this bro
that was a very stupid mistake i should
have bought that that would be my first
one on the ladder do you know what i'm
saying they give you a discount bloody
bloody blood whatever
but
even though i had the information
it wasn't coming from
a success story it wasn't coming from
someone that had done it before
do you get what i'm saying so now i'm
the first one that's like yo
where are you going to rent like
think about what you're doing because
then even myself like i wasn't even in
princess part mana forever
and even in there like i wasn't ever
like thinking about buying property
and they were like don't you want to buy
the one that you're in i was like nah
i'm not going to be here forever like in
in my eyes property was
you buy to live not buy to let and you
can't move yeah i'm saying in my head
i'm thinking no i'm going to buy where
i'm going to live but i'm like i never
really
understood that no you can buy and move
and just own it and then rent it
yourself you know what i'm saying i
didn't really understand
the principle of that
so um
i understand
i understand why it happens i understand
why
we we want all these trophies i get it
but i think it's it's about
people like myself
who can now conversate with the with the
young a lot and be like look man like i
get it it looks nice
but bro like this music is game of
thrones bro
music is game you see game of thrones
they killed the main character bro do
you want they don't mind doing that
music is game of thrones bro you're
michael jackson on monday your t.o
jackson on tuesday bro like and then you
can be michael again by sunday you get
i'm saying like the mute it's musical
chairs bro like you have to understand
we're not
always going to be number one forever so
just make sure
you're buying a foundation for your
foundation man
yeah when you had you know your first
big breakthrough moment at the time did
you
somewhere in your mind think that this
was
meant that you would be number one
forever is there a part of you that goes
oh we've done it now in terms of like
now i know the the uh the equation
yeah a bit of complacency maybe
i kind of think like the more you
understand because obviously but at that
time there's a
there's a route to get to number one and
it's like
your song's launched
by mr jam or annie mack
and then
the pre-order's out
and then you go for playlisting on radio
one one extra capital and there's like a
there's a route that puts you
on the pitch
do you get what i'm saying attention to
it yeah to get it so there's all the
steps so
but the problem is
you can't believe in the route
more than you believe in the fruit
so you can't think that
this root can work with whatever fruit
you give it do you get i'm saying you
still
still has to be an apple bro
like it still has to be fruitful it
still has to be a record a sick record
you get what i'm saying so then
you know you you like we've had some
records that i thought yeah like there's
one or two that i thought like the root
can carry it and then when the root
don't carry it you realize like that
this
is not work every time you don't once
again you don't
you don't just
you don't get 10 heads in a row bro you
get i'm saying you get toes one time and
then it's and then it's how you bounce
back from that have you had to talk to
me about bouncing back from that then
because
you know
even as a fan of yours like i'll play
i'll play records of yours when they
drop and i'll be like i'll say it say to
my boys i'm like we got this little chat
on whatsapp i'll say this one is a
[ __ ] like this was um i'm like this
one's gonna be right and then it might
not get there and another one might you
must have that all the time and how do
you manage the expectation of like
building creating a project
you believing that it's x y and z i mean
i do that with these podcasts as well
you just never know and which episode's
going to bang right
and then putting it out there
and that bit being out of your control
how does that feel like and if you had
moments like that when you've created
something and put out there you go what
you have to understand that that's the
side that we're not in control of
do you get i'm saying like
and as an artist just
make it for you
make it for you put your best foot
forward but make it for you
because
if i make a song
that i think is rubbish but i think
everyone's gonna like yeah and i put a
song out everybody likes it it goes to
number one
i now have to perform this song
this song is in my discography this is
in my catalogue like
my
great-great-great-grandkids are going to
hear this song see i'm saying and not
even i've had a conversation with me
that's going to be their representation
of their great great great great great
grandfather
be proud of your art man
do you get what i'm saying be proud of
it so for me it's like
i put my blood
sweat tears and skin in my album when it
comes out if they like it
if they don't like it
what can i i can't i can't do anything
more than i done and i and i put my best
foot forward and i think
you have to live by that man because you
either
you you either have the hit that you
don't like
or you put out the record that you don't
like and it's not a hit
so now you've got
now you're wrestling back to get back to
where you was for something you didn't
even like anyway
do you get i'm saying just put your best
foot forward man and stay true to
yourself yeah stay true to yourself man
because it's your this is your legacy
like me now
i try and look at my
like it all made sense to me when i
started
seeing my career from the end till
today
and i'm like
what what
what navigates me is will i be happy
with this at the end
so i make a song today and i'm listening
to the tune and i'm like
will i be happy with this at the end
can work for today then but if i feel
like at the end i might feel like oh
i don't think you should have put that
one out it's not worth it
it's not worth it it's not worth it bro
oh yeah what we get what we got how many
we get 80 years maybe now whatever you
like your legacy can
can triple that bro do you what i'm
saying like have the right one have the
right one you've got you're in control
of that that's what you are in control
of and you've had a taste of the like
the empty nature of like fame and like
people writing about you every single
second and people running up and falling
and all this stuff you've tasted that so
what what have you learned about
what that means being on dragons then
now i get it a little bit more so i get
people coming up to me and stuff and i'm
in the early stages of like figuring out
what it means to you know like have
daily mail reporters standing outside
the house here and taking photos of
being my girlfriend when we walk out and
i'm trying to understand what this
attention means is it something i can
use does it make me feel good what is it
it it didn't make me feel good man
i didn't that's one thing i've i've
always
wanted to be in the shadows like i've
always not wanted that part of it some
people understand how to use it though
do you get i'm saying because say for
example you're
you're designing clothing
and it's like every time they shoot you
they're putting it in a magazine i'm
saying like you're being
you're being mass exposed and your
clothing is being mass exposed but it's
like if you don't have
if you don't wish for that if you don't
desire for that
then it's like i feel like it's
it was useless for me being
in the front of certain magazines for
for nothing like nothing artistic
do you i mean i know people say like
any publicity is good publicity i'm like
sometimes you can just be
famous for nothing and no one wants to
be the guy that's like
the most famous person in the world and
no money
do you know what i mean or like not not
and i don't say money like to be rich i
just mean like
everyone knows who you are and
everywhere you're walking you're
stopping and he's having a conversation
taking a picture taking it taking it out
taking it out but like your thing's not
in order like you're not going to feel
good being that person
so like i just yeah i never i never
really liked it man i never liked it man
i was the one i was hiding from the
patch man all the time in your comment
but did you ever experience what they
call like imposter syndrome walking into
rooms and feeling like what the [ __ ] am
i doing here or
being in situations and going like i
don't know if i deserve this that voice
inside
for a shoot period of time but you know
who made me overcome that richard entomy
like he passed away but this he's such a
champion this guy
would walk he walks into any meeting
fearlessly
any like you could be sitting down with
the head of hmv or d and he's going to
tell them yeah you need to take twenty
thousand of our cds and did it and
you're just like
right like you're just
like he made me feel like
you're you bro
like you're gold you're the gold as well
you know you're gold bro like don't now
walk into that room and because you
think everything in here is is gold
becomes silver no no i'm cold as well
i'm saying and i think
being around him and then that drip down
to my manager zeon as well and he's got
that thing as well where
bro we were like we were having like i
remember i remember we were um
we done a thing with lukaszade where
they put us on like on the balls yeah on
the bottles yeah and i remember like i
was sitting down and we were like
tapping each other so like yeah what do
you want to put on the bottles like yeah
man
you want to put our estate
on but i'm thinking they're going to say
no but they're like yeah yeah that would
be sick like yeah picture of our state
yeah yeah what else
yeah man and this and that and i
realized i was like you can get
the things that you think you can't get
you can get like you are the gold as
well there's a reason why lucas aide
want to partner up with retreats you
know what i'm saying like there's a
reason
and it's like sometimes we think it's
they're so big they don't
but any it's a it's a two-way thing it's
a two-way street so i think
yeah for a short period of time i did
but then
like zeon
richard twin like they just they just
made me understand the importance of
like knowing your worth yeah knowing
your worth and just being fearless man
just walking into any room as me
like and and
like i did feel that as well at certain
times because obviously now we see the
festival lineups like wireless and all
that like you see miss banks you see
stef london you see
gets you see gigs you see you see so
many names 2011 it wasn't like that bro
you see tiny
might see chip she rich do you get i'm
saying it was like or certain festivals
i'm the only representative of this
genre
so it's like when you're stepping into
that
like then you're feeling like if i mess
up like if i even forget one line of my
lyric they ain't booking no one next
year do you get what i'm saying so it's
like then
you've got this thing where it's like
the fights on where you're fighting for
the scene you know i mean and you've got
to wear it like a badger honor i
remember like
doing glastonbury and like
the guy who
like books the tent like standing on the
side or whatever i can't remember what
facebook was but it was standing on the
side like it's asking me bare questions
like why do you have two drummers
it's just like
bro i've got electronic sounds on my
album he plays electric he plays
acoustic like so the the music's gonna
sound exactly like the record oh how
come you
set a stage up like this how come how
come like so many questions that i don't
feel like he was asking anyone else he
just wanted to check if we knew what we
was doing
and at that point to be fair not
everyone's shooting in the dark
i'm saying everyone's we're all guessing
bro at that point we're all shooting in
the dark just don't be the casualty
don't be the one that gets hit that was
that was the theory so um
[Music]
yeah we just
felt our way through but them times i
did used to feel a little thing but then
afterwards i was like nah man i'm coming
like we're coming we've got stuff to add
i've got hit records as well they want
to hear us
and then the festival lineup needs to be
more diverse like we're ten years after
that now and the festival lineup is more
diverse but i do feel like at that time
if tiny temple wasn't turning up or chip
wasn't doing what he had to do even
professor green wasn't doing what he had
to do i mean
she had to do what he had we had to get
it right and we had to or we i don't
know if we'd be here today when you come
from the estate like you do
and you end up in these like boardrooms
and these fancy meetings with these you
know
rich white men in suits
um
what i see in a lot of like young
young people from those those kind of
backgrounds is they kind of walk through
life with a bit of a
an expectation that the cards are
stacked against them yeah and i i worry
sometimes that that belief
whether it's true or false it is often
true
the belief that the cards are stacked
against you
can be
equally or more harmful than the cards
actually being stacked against you yeah
do you know what i mean yeah the belief
of the cosmetics against you can be the
deterrent of you even playing the game
exactly do you know what i'm saying i
don't even want to deal now like don't
do me anything there's no point i'm
going to lose anyway
you know what i'm saying but
i don't know what that comes from but i
was fortunate man like i can't i can't
say it enough like richard anthony
like just
just a g he was a lawyer he was a lawyer
as well a music lawyer so he
he understood that side as well so he
could he could speak whatever language
do you get what i'm saying at any table
he could like if they started talking
about split some points he can he can go
there with you do you i'm saying so when
you're
walking into a game with that bro you're
you ha you're fearless bro quick one as
you might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewellery the
really wonderful thing about crafted
jewelry is it's super affordable it
looks amazing the pieces hold tremendous
meaning and they are really well made i
think i've worn this piece for almost a
year
it hasn't broken hasn't changed colour
because it's really really good quality
and it costs roughly 50 quid people will
be surprised when they hear that they'll
probably assume that all of my jewelry
is like solid gold and cost thousands
and thousands of pounds but what's the
point when you can achieve the exact
same effect from a piece of jewelry
that's high quality and cost 50 quid
that's why i buy crafted green machine
you started this business with your um
business partner
and it's um now i believe the
the largest cbd
shop in europe by the number of shops
that you have a number of stores square
feet they say square feet tell me about
green machine
green machine um if i'm honest i'm
someone who like
don't believe in paracetamols
i don't like take stuff like that
a mate of mine was always telling me
that like he's going into this
cbd space and i'm like
what's cbd and he's like
it's basically a natural alternative
to medicine
so i'm like okay it's gonna be it's
gonna be the future that it's going to
be the future so i'm like all right cool
what does it do
he's like well people come in cancer
patients people with ms people with
fibromyalgia people with lupus people
that can't sleep people that suffer with
severe headaches
okay and what does it do for them it
wouldn't say it cures them but
it helps them manage
their illness
so i'm like all right cool
so to me this sounds like paracetamol
because i don't believe in paracetamol
it don't work on me so i haven't i don't
need to i don't take it i haven't taken
it for years so i'm right cool
so i can't link him and i get
all the products
yeah i get all the products
and i give it out to family members
someone's got fibromyalgia can you just
try and just tell me what happens like
it's absolutely nothing to do with me
just give me honest feedback
severe headaches you can't sleep anxiety
whatever giving out giving it out
everyone came back and was like
i couldn't sleep i'm now sleeping
or
the times when i was having
joint problems i'm rubbing the cream on
and
i'm okay so i'm like
all right cool i haven't told these
people this might potentially be
anything to do with me they're just
being honest so i'm like all right cool
what do i have that i can personally try
so i'm like
all right i can't sleep
so let's try some of the others try some
of the olds bro i'm sleeping i'm like
all right this is a real thing so then
like
i was like cool let me have a
conversation with
like the actual founder yeah uh a guy
called paul which is absolute
genius in this realm and i'm like what's
your story
he's like well chronic arthritis
and he literally
like has a cannabis background but he
was using cbd to help manage his pain
and he was like well why can't we
you know
open it as a business and you know start
start moving forward and helping people
you know um
so yeah and then i was just like
i haven't like put
a lot of time focus on money into a lot
of other things other than music and
i've always been waiting to find
something
but i wanted to fight like i didn't want
to go that down a clothing route like i
want
something that reflects who i am i'm an
individual who likes
to help people
do you i'm saying like
a people's person
and i honestly think like this is like
the future
of medicine man like and so hopefully
you know it will go down the route where
you'll become prescribed like if you
look at
if you and and for us it's like it's
about
growing a business
we're hoping to have like between 50 and
75 stores within the next three years
wow
um
and hopefully if it goes to the point
where
it it does turn into like a former
chemist like the fingers of the chemist
you go there and you're like i've got
a headache what can i take
they recommend you think oh i've got
itch on my back you can actually speak
to someone and they can tell you oh no
no you're better off getting that cream
that works better for you cool like we
want to be
that kind of version
for people that come in because it's
it's it's a two-way educational street
because people are coming in a lot of
people coming with ms a lot of people
coming with cancer and i'm like as much
as
everyone in the stores are equipped to
tell them there's still new things to
learn and there's like still new ideas
for different products and it's just a
new
space that you know i get to to put some
focus in and this is
is something that i think is is honestly
going to benefit people as well
and we've tried a lot of the products
they're all amazing this one actually
tastes amazing as well the grapefruit
and mint drink and we went down there
earlier we got some coffees
and some other and some of the oils and
stuff the creams that i'm going to try
as well super interesting the other
thing that you're involved in which i
think is a fairly new thing is the def
jam position so you're now the creative
director there yeah that's though
that is just mad yeah it's i'm working
with a like such a cold bunch man like
everyone everyone's extremely talented
man and
i think for me more than anything like a
sick to be on this side
because understanding it from the other
side like being the artist coming into
an office or coming into an environment
i'm gonna know
the answers to a lot of the things what
they're asking because i've been through
it as well
so um
always on my come up like i've always
worked
or had long conversations with artists
that are coming like whether it be
stormzy would be avalino it would be
young and krypton whoever whoever it may
be
and i think like there was never like a
role or a title
or nothing and it's like you're not
doing that for money or for finance like
you literally want to see the game
nourish you want to see
everyone blossom
so it's like
the games got bigger
and i think now
it's about
showing that we're able to work in the
infrastructure and add value do you know
what i'm saying like it's it's valuable
our artist being inside to be able to
speak to eyes you know i'm saying to be
able to create to be able to implement
ideas because what happens is you
like i say like you we jumped on a train
at the beginning of 2011 and it just
moved and then i i had to meet a tour
manager and i had to meet a booking
agent and all these things and it's like
i can literally talk you through
everything step by step and that's like
if we're signing artists at ground zero
sometimes there's artists that already
put a paper he's already here already
established
he signed to us um
but it's like just having artistic
conversations with artists do you know
what i mean and
i think it's beautiful man i wake up and
think ah wake up and think creative so
to be able to be in a space where i'm
able to do that with artists that i love
and respect with people that i love and
respect as well
win-win man yeah
earlier on you said till death do us
part notice you um you don't have a
wedding ring on
no no no
no what's the situation now you're in a
relationship you're dating or sir uh
yeah in a relationship not married have
you struggled with relationships or have
you have you found it being a fairly
obsessive person because throughout your
story i had i saw this word hunger over
and over again yeah other people
described you and i'm thinking back to
ashley on that kitchen table getting
annoyed at you you know yeah i think i'm
understanding balance a lot more
i think that's come with maturity
and that's come with age like balance is
important
i had no balance back then
none it was all
about making this happen and i don't
know if it's because
it happened do you know what i'm saying
maybe if it doesn't happen maybe
we don't get this version of me where
i'm more understanding that
you've got a divide time i think also
what was a big eye opener for me like
once again talking about jumping on that
train yeah um
from like
2011 to 2014 15
bro certain times my family's having
conversations yet and
i'm like when was that
i know like that was when you was
off
yeah it's like i was it's like i was
dead for four years i was just off the
grid and it's like
it's never ever sat well with me do you
know what i'm saying so now like i make
a conscious effort conscious decision to
be like as someone who is the back the
backbone and the head of the family to
be it
i'm saying because there's two
there's two types
of of you know of men that hit the
family and this and it's one that
everyone's financially okay and when if
there's any red letters
but then there's a there's the one
that's
able to do that but is also there as
well like a hour on the phone or
let's go and sit down and talk for four
hours is
as powerful as someone who can make a
bill vanished you get what i'm saying
and i think in 2011
i was more the other guy yeah i'll show
it out i get um phone this person they
can sort it out phone like someone can
sort it out
i'm shooting it out but it was like
i'm missing and it doesn't make me feel
good i miss graduations and
do you know i mean like so much things
that because you're busy they might not
invite you to now because we asked you
to come last week but you couldn't make
it like i was generally out the country
but maybe i could have made that one but
you didn't ask you know what i mean so
it's like it doesn't feel good man i
think i'm probably ready like a guy now
it's horrible yeah and not giving enough
attention to
family in that regard like how do you
how did you balance it
with my family it really really it's a
really difficult thing um they kind of
live all over the place as well so they
don't all live in one place so
really like what i do is i try and bring
everyone together for christmas and i
fund the situation at christmas um but i
know i'm not doing a good enough job and
it's something i want to work on
fortunately i met a young lady who
is very unnegotiable about balance yeah
and like i genuinely feel that if i
don't
i've got make sure my terminology is
correct here because sometimes sometimes
when people describe their relationships
especially people that are really
obsessive they start to use words like
which is which
which
make it seem like i'm doing something to
please someone
so that they don't go yeah well it's not
i want to do it
but she has given me the desire to want
to be balanced in my life
which means like
today
during the work day i went for lunch
with her then came back quickly and like
carried on with my research on you and
stuff i would never have done that
before yeah i would have just woken up
in the morning eight o'clock and i would
have worked till one a.m until i'd
fallen asleep and then i would have said
to whoever i was with
probably kind of like gaslighted them in
some way and said like ah you don't
understand yeah
no no you found the right person then
yeah because then you want to
then i want to do it
yeah then you want to do it you know
what i'm saying then you want to
it's about balance man it's about
balance and even me with the kids as
well like
my son's 15 yeah yeah my dude was 10
it's like
that balance as well like it
you know at the time when i had my dual
arm we then
you know then but we separated
and it was like it hurts me like my
daughter she has no record recognition
of living with me
do you know what i'm saying it's like
she's like yeah yeah my mom said like
like you used to live like i'm like what
do you mean yeah i used to of course i'd
used to live there you should wake up
when you come to me and i remember
then i'm like
you i need to over extend to build this
relationship because my son has that
we've had that
waking up him going to sleep waking up
seeing me do you know what i'm saying
and it's just them little things
where it's like
like the kids will come over
and
i'll be like oh we're going to do this
and my daughter might say to me i have
to ask my mom
she's like her concept of a dad was
probably more like an uncle yeah do you
know what i mean like you know like to
your uncle you say no i gotta ask my mom
but not to your dad but
it's like she had to i was like no no i
mean i'm on the same level
do you know what i'm saying but because
she's not seeing me every day
like or waking up to me or do you know
what i mean i'm not tucking her in i was
just like bro
i had to that it was so important that
we we get here we get here we get and
we're here now but it took
it takes time to rebuild man so it's
better
you build it than have to rebuild as
well
what if um you know when you were shot
on those cds and trying to get people to
buy those first thousand cities from
your mixtape line for my mixtape
what if it just hadn't worked out
has that ever crossed your mind what if
just you know
what if it didn't didn't work out
it had to
it had to like the plan b was revert
back to plan a
anytime you felt like you needed to
remotely think about doing something
else it was revert back to plan a it was
always
it was always going to happen there's a
lot of people that think that and it
just doesn't work out you know like yeah
i want you a little bit just
i think
my need was too much man my need was to
i
became too good at it like the obsession
made me better made me more hungry
i just i just became a monster man i
just
i'm like no one can rap like a rap do
you know what i'm saying but that's
because
i'm listening to everyone rapping and
i'm like all right cool how
right this is what they're doing yeah
like all right triple rhymes cool i'll
do quadruple do you get i'm saying like
i was always
trying to challenge trying to push
trying to push trying to push and like
when you've been rapping like when your
year group is like gets volcano or i
mean or giggs or whatever like that
that's like man's age group they're my
age mate so it's like when
you're listening to gets and he's doing
that you're like cool i can't even
flip a second you know i'm saying i've
got a i've got a push i've got a push
i've got a push i can't it had to happen
man
i don't see any the story wasn't ending
any other way or like the story wasn't
having any other middle and what would
you say to musicians that you know are
now coming up in this world of tick tock
and
you know what what do they what do you
think they need to to make it and to
follow in your footsteps
i mean now that you also know the
industry as well in the mechanics of
that because tick-tock is tick-tock is
powerful now man
it's the new
taste makers the new
the library yes the new discovery man
and it's like
so remember when i said that there was a
formula
and it was like if that dj plays it
first on thursday and then
tick tock is a part of that formula now
like you put a song on that sounds a
certain way it gets a certain amount of
views
and
that's an indicator to the record labels
that this song is going to be
amongst
you know on the playing field of the hit
playing field
it's it's become that
and i think you can use it to your
advantage but i guess
once again like
the part we are in control of
is the song is the quality
like
always make sure the quality is
top-notch regardless because all the
things everything else will change bro
like michael jackson put out
tapes
vinyls
now
chris brown goes
on streaming platforms do you know what
i'm saying and
i launched records on radio first now
they launched records on tick-tock foot
like the everything will change well but
the quality
will always remain
you can't skip it you can't skip leg day
man
you're at me then
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where um the last guest writes
the question for the next guest
and they don't know who they're writing
it for they always ask but we never tell
them so they've actually written two
questions which is interesting the the
first question they wrote i'm going to
read them both at the same time is
what for you is the life well-lived and
then they wrote how do you make the most
of this moment
so what for you as a life well lived and
how do you make the most of this moment
a life well lived
is
waking up every day
and having multiple reasons to smile
and within that making multiple people
smile
um i always think like
life is a record it's not a record
put the needle on
and it comes inwards
so it's coming inwards just getting
smaller and smaller and smaller then it
gets to the end in the middle and it
stops
and my thing is like
what song are you listening to
why your
your your time span is shooting and is
it
something that's
that's that's that's full of purpose
something that's making you smile and
something that's
energizing other people
and
and and for me it's like
i want to be able to be
a positive soundtrack
for key moments in other people's lives
as well
so life well-lived is me being happy
bringing happiness
and being able to
also add
a soundtrack
to people's happiest moments
though very part sir and then the second
question was how do you make the most of
this moment how do i make the most of
this moment live in it man
live in it
and i think
appreciate it as well
i think um
i say living it because
it's it's it's easy to be on that train
i keep going back to that train it's
easy to be on that train and just to
keep going keep going keep going but
for me
we don't meet anyone for no reason
there's no meaningless conversation
you know there's always something to
take from a conversation that you
thought what the hell was that about do
you know what i'm saying
because we're all bro we're all like
we're all seeds bro we're all seeds that
grow into fruit bro we're all seed so if
you're you're having a conversation
someone's planting something that can
become fruitful later on
so
to make the best of this moment just
live in it
do you know i mean don't just be in it
live in it man be present
thank you thank you thank you it's been
such a great conversation and it's a
real privilege to me like i said i've
been a student for a long time and i'm
still a mega fan um
all right upon reflection
i think it's probably gonna be
in my little spotify rap thing as some
of the most
played song album that i think you've
released recently and uh yeah it was
that 2019 yeah it feels like it was you
know it feels like it was more recent
than that for some reason maybe that's
because i still spin it but tasmanian we
lost two years as well in it no no i
genuinely say this i have i have this
debate with my my one of my
long-standing best friends and i
genuinely think lyrically in terms of
subject matter and art i think you're
the goat in our country so thank you and
i think a lot of people share that
opinion so it's a huge honor to have you
here and then your wisdom thank you
brother love man thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]